good day everyone welcome I'm Jack Van
Horton from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2020 3 2024
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to differing themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences our theme this year
is focused on the building of
Partnerships for generative AI training
in biomedical and clinical research
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from a wide range of leading thinkers
about the issues promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with the emerging
Notions of AI methods applied to
biomedical science and the data types
and efforts of Faculty Educators in
training the next generation of
biomedical researchers to properly
utilize these new computational tools
indeed we would like to remind folks
that our 2023 2024 application cycle is
now open and we encourage Junior faculty
members working in areas such as
development of generative AI based
methods applied to biomedical research
and those Junior faculty actively
utilizing AI in their biomedical
teaching to consider applying we believe
this to be an exciting and engaging
program bringing together AI platform
developers and University level
Educators to better understand and power
the promise and potential Perils of
associated with generative uh AI
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program
leverage seminars such as the one we're
going to hear today as vital material
for our culminating iners manuscript and
Grant development Workshop to be held at
the Bahia beachfront Resort located in
San Diego California in June of 2024
today I am absolutely delighted to
welcome our speaker Susan Gregor from
the National Institutes of Health Dr
Gregor which is was appointed as the
associate director for data science and
the director for the office of data
science strategy or the odss at the
National Institutes of Health on
September 16th
2019 under her leadership the odss leads
the implementation of the nih's
Strategic plan for data science through
scientific Technical and operational
collaboration with across all the
Institute centers and offices Which comp
um comp comprise the NIH Dr Gregor
received the 2020 leadership in
biological sciences award from the
Washington Academy of Science for her
work in this role she was instrumental
in the creation of the odss in 2018 and
has served as is a senior adviser to the
office until being named to her current
position as the Director in continuing
our 2023 2024 biomedical data science in
um seminar series theme Susan's lecture
today is entitled Innovations and
challenges in Ai and its applications to
health Susan will note that advances in
the field of AI have led to exciting
opportunities including improvements in
protein structure prediction protein
design computer AED diagnosis on medical
images better understanding of things
like long covid and the use of large
language models to interp clinical
electronic health care records and
reports which Aid clinical decision
support her talk today will outline the
nih's support for artificial
intelligence methodologies highlighting
new Innovations and challenges in AI
applications to health and engage
participants in discussions um on the
future of biomedical AI as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you're
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2023 2024 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are welcome to submit any
questions they have via the chat feature
in their YouTube sessions um I'll be
synthesizing these questions and asking
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that Susan welcome we are very excited
to be hearing from you today and really
looking forward to your
presentation thank you so much um I'm
delighted to be here today it's
wonderful to be a part of the um of the
meeting and happy holidays to everybody
I don't know if I was supposed to uh
flip through these slides or not but I'm
just doing it now so you can see them
and uh as Jack noted I am the associate
director for data science and I'll talk
to you a little bit about building
Partnerships for generative Ai and the
work that we're doing at NIH in
artificial intelligence but let me Begin
by telling you a few stories about
what's happening now uh in AI in in
generative Ai and the first story is the
top one it's the story of um Tim elof
and his colleagues to develop a a system
called Haley it's an AI in the loop
agent that provides just in time Fe Fe
back to um students or participants who
want to participate in peer-to-peer
mentoring um and who need uh support um
many college students of course do need
support So Haley is a peer-to-peer um
generative AI algorithm that gives the
peer mentors prompts for empathetic um
responses to their mentee their peer
mentees and this was um benchmarked um
on talk life uh which is an online
peer-to-peer support platform and what
they found in publica not too surprising
is that utilizing generative AI the peer
mentors were able to um increase their
conversational empathy overall and so
certainly you know these types of
generative AI tools to provide um prompt
responses is something that I think uh
is we're going to see quite a bit of
increase in not just in research but
also in development and Technology the
second vignette is down there on the
lower um left hand side the two robots
who are talking and it's a story about
um utilizing chat gbt 4 to um diagnose
complex medical cases and of course it's
not too surprising that um chat gp4 is
much uh more improved in in correctly
diagnosing cases especially those cases
um where there's a lot of uh reading um
of images but one thing that I have
noted recently is that Eric Horwitz just
recently put out a paper on the archive
on the on the Improvement of chat pt4 in
um uh answering medical questions and
benchmarking medical questions by using
generalized prompts and in context
learning so you know typically and I've
been saying this too that um what's
needed for uh utilizing medical AI is
those um specialized large language
models like Med Palm but what uh Hartz
is saying is that look if we if we
develop generative prompts or
generalized prompts with in context
learning we really don't need um
specialized large language models so
this is really something to look at and
pay attention to and the last vignette
is by Dr Z and his collaborators down
there on the bottom right and it's
really the story of the usage of medical
AI devices across the United States and
sa and his colleagues have tracked this
by tracking the current Pro procedural
terminology codes the CPT codes um and
they're looking at Medical Centers
medical institutions and what they find
and this is not going to surprise you is
that um de medical devices that are
adopting um AI have the largest uh
success rate and largest impact in
assessing things like coronary artery
disease and uh diabetic retinal opathy
um but where they're really implemented
the most are in ZIP codes with higher uh
uh annual income as well as uh ZIP codes
where there's an active Medical Center
an academic Medical Center just like at
UVA um and so this really points to
where some a lack of adoption and
medical AI devices uh is happening and
we at nihh are paying attention to this
and we're really thinking about how do
you reach a broader Community for AI and
that is something I'm going to hit later
on in the talk so I'd like to show this
it's probably going to be outdated now
but this is really the first few months
of just utilizing chat GPT in
Publications as measured through looking
at Pub Med and what you can see since
December 2022 is that there's been a
study increase in the this is actually a
study that was published I'll give the
reference in a moment and where I'm
interested stud of course is in the
medical adoption of AI and biomedical
adoption and where you can see the
largest adoption is in ethics and
clinical practice and biomedical
education it's worth looking at this
it's also worth um you know following
along as researchers look at the
adoption of things like chat GPT or
generative AI uh in research and I'll
get to that in a minute as well so what
I thought I would just give a really
quick introduction I'll talk about the
cloud and some of our larger data
science initi IES a little bit about
artificial intelligence and then I'd
love to tell you about some training
opportunities um both here within NIH as
wealth within the community so as Jack
said I am uh a director of an office the
office of data science strategy we sit
in deep at kipy people know deep at kipy
division of planning coordination
strategic initiatives U mostly through
the common fund but there are 14 offices
in deep pipy all of us coordinate and
catalyze different types of science
across in our 27 Institute centers and
offices and of course we're working on
data science um so we we're looking to
modernize and integrate our biomedical
data ecosystem and at the same time
enhance training for a diverse and
talented D data science Workforce and
building strong Partnerships I won't
talk too too much about our Partnerships
with NSF and doe and onc and others U
but that is an in our um in our mandate
as well so let me tell you a little bit
about what we're doing in cloud
computing because um AI has two parts of
the uh the equation Computing and data
so let me tell you first about Computing
and the work we're doing in um in that
and I love this quote this is from Dave
Glazer and Alex Tas uh who said that you
know if you move everything to the cloud
you don't need to have your on premise
data center to do research you can
actually do research at a global scale
by utilizing cloud-based tools um that
could take advantage of ped meytes of
biomedical data and from that analysis
you can identify patterns and markers
for disease for predict prediction and
for causality so let's see um how far we
are along in that uh
hypothesis so through our partnership
and our Partnership of science
technology research infrastructure for
Discovery experimentation and
sustainability or strides is a
partnership with Google with AWS and
with Microsoft aure in we get a lot from
this partnership not only do we get
competitive pricing um for cloud storage
and compute but we also get expert
support services from our cloud service
providers that help us do things like
optimize our workflows to um not only
take advantage of the cloud but take
advantage of that both at a scale that's
on the petabyte uh region but also on
the time scale by optimizing those
workflows we also get training expertise
um from our cloud service providers
professional consult cons and reach
through to additional partners and you
can see the impact on the right hand
side the the amount of data on the cloud
is really quite impressive you know one
petabyte of data is equivalent to about
230,000 uh high quality movie DVDs so
that's just a lot of biomedical data in
the cloud we're also competitive in
terms of a high performance Computing
environment with over 56 million compute
hours reaching over 1,700 85 programs
and uh training a significant number of
folks that everyone from undergrads to
uh to establish research investigators
pis but one of the things I'm the most
excited about um is the cloud lab and
the cloud lab is you know think of this
as a Sandbox this uh took a little while
to stand up but we have been operational
since June 23d of this past year and
what you can do in the sandbox is you
can utilize car uh utility and Cloud
cost so think of this as a try before
you buy type of sandbox you can look at
um what it might be like to develop some
new tools in the cloud you can share
ideas with researchers and you can most
importantly learn skills in the cloud
and we have a number of uh training
modules and data in Cloud lab that you
can play with and look at and you can
see that we have three different Cloud
Labs so you can try AWS you can try
Google or you can try Microsoft asure
and each one might have a slightly
different flavor and Nuance to it you
have an ability to try it there um free
of charge uh it's not a forever thing
you get a certain amount of credit hours
and time uh and then you know you can
make some decisions about is cloud right
for you and for your research it's also
really great if you're uh have some
students and you like them to experiment
with the
cloud so here's some of the things about
what it is and what it is not it is not
a place to do production research you
don't have enough Cloud credits or
enough um capabilities in Cloud lab to
do your actual research this is truly a
Sandbox um it is only for researchers
who are interested in our strides
program because it's part of strides um
and it is a place um to work but you
can't work with uh uh sensitive data um
and it is an environment um that uh is
NIH manage and you can have full access
to the cloud ciles um so there's just a
a lot of stuff that you can do so if
you're interested in stride and you
really want to try it out I I hope that
you'll give it a try and also you'll
give us some
feedback so with over 250 pedabytes of
data in the cloud and you can see the
different types of data everything from
genomics and phenotypic data all the way
down to cryoem data and imaging data
this is quite a lot it's also a
challenge and sometimes it's a Grand
Challenge because um you know searching
and utilizing the data at that scale is
really hard where're we continually work
on how to optimize search and how to
optimize analytics at this scale I won't
tell you about all the wonderful
platforms that we have at NIH that are
on the cloud and the ways in which we're
stitching these together through
interoperability capabilities to create
sort of a fabric of a data ecos system
um but um I will say that this is
something for another talk and hopefully
we follow up I would like to just I love
this uh comment by um Louis n emal who
uh likes to who likes to remind me that
you know in the analogy of data to crude
oil you know actually making data useful
and getting it out to our colleagues
through the biomedical rese research uh
ecosystem really does require a large
investment both in the extraction of the
data the curation of it the
harmonization the refinement and then
the ways in which we make it accessible
to researchers and all of those
components are components that NIH and
my office are working on what can you
expect in the future where are we going
we're connecting our money Data Systems
towards a step that would improve the
fairness and the value of data in our
ecosystem by enhancing the utility of
cloud and looking towards hyber
Computing architectures we're supporting
efficiencies and sharable Technologies
in and across our NIH data platforms and
at the same time we want to improve
researchers access to data in particular
to sensitive data while still having
accountability for privacy protections
and security I can say that through some
really wonderful work that my office and
our colleagues at nlm and across the
ic's have done we've been able to reduce
the amount of time that researchers uh
have when they request genomics data
through dbgap from about two plus weeks
to less than a couple hours so I'm
really really proud of that efficiency
that we've been able to do uh and
finally we're looking to connect as I
said our data ecosystems I I'm very
interested in my colleagues as well in
interoperability and to enhance our
ability for data Discovery and search
and with that the one thing I will say
is that I'm proud to be a partner and a
member of the NSF Proto open knowledge
Network the OK supporting a center that
will look at how we can develop um
knowledge graphs that will allow
researchers to find and utilize open
data so data that is not controlled
access um throughout the many different
repositories and systems that are
supported not just by ni but also by NSF
and other
agencies let me tell you a little bit
about um some of our larger data science
initiatives um because some of these
initiatives really do have ai ready data
let me talk quickly about the all of us
program a program that will accelerate
our health research and medical
breakthroughs um and so by this
program we have a significant number of
data in the all us program and the
really nice thing about this data is
that it's harmonized and it's linked so
that you can utilize it for your
investigations so for example there are
um over 254,000 participants donating
their electronic healthc care record
information and their genomics data
there's survey data there's personal
Family Health Data and why is that
important it gives you a trajectory a
time of all of the health um and health
related uh encounters that people have
oops I'm sorry that was my fault and
then there's also bitten physical
measurements in all of us programs so
got a link there down to the the data
browser it's a opportunity for you to
utilize data that's really truly at
scale and at the availability for AI
research
hi I think um the one thing I should
have mentioned is that my internet is
sometimes unstable so let me reshare my
screen uh I apologize for that moving
forward I hope that you caught the um
component about um am ahead I mean sorry
about all of us so let me tell you
quickly about some of the um work that's
been done with um all of us there's over
200 Publications in the all of us um
using all of us data so far and the
first one that I want to highlight is
from Dr Fang he's able to address
factors um about uh utilizing the
electronic healthc care record in the a
in the all of us program to look at the
uh evidence of breast cancer that might
be uh strongly positively associated
with total cholesterol and low density
lipoproteins um so there's a that's a
nice paper there to look at how you can
use electronic Healthcare records to
understand um cholesterol and breast
cancer there's a really nice program uh
and paper uh by delar uh which is
looking at the the cost related barriers
to medication adherence both by race and
ethnicity um in the all of us program
with patients with glycom not surprising
what you will see is that uh patients
who um are uh non-hispanic
African-American as well as Hispanic
individuals have a much more difficult
time of 40 medications compared to
non-hispanic White individuals and the
last uh vignette to to highlight is um
the hypertension alas um paper which
really uh is a long longitudal data
study of hypertension Nationwide um to
develop a precis precise rule-based
algorithm for in hypertension treatment
and prevention and the nice thing about
this paper is that it's Benchmark and
compare it against nines and the results
are quite similar telling me that the
data in the alos program is very robust
and also um ready for large scale
use so let me just quickly highlight
that there's some really nice work that
you can get support for for using the
all of us uh researcher workbench um
supported both by uh the human genome
Research Institute insute as well as the
National Institute for biomedical
Imaging and bioengineering this is
program is to support early stage
investigators and new investigators from
diverse backgrounds so if you're
interested in um in utilizing the data
that I just explained or you have
additional data that would support uh
the missions of niib or nhgri please
consider applying for this uh potential
um a funding announcement and I'm so
sorry that I forgot to put the date out
but please look at it because the date
may be expiring
soon let me tell you a little bit about
some of the work that we're doing in
artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence and
accelerating trustworthy AI is certainly
a priority it's not just a priority of
NIH or of Health and Human Services HHS
it's a priority of our Administration
and you can see that through the number
of types of Publications that have come
up um both through the federal registry
and promoting the use of trustworthy Ai
and the federal government as well as
the AI bill of rights as well as all of
the Strategic plans from HHS on AI but
most
importantly this um past October October
30th the president put out an executive
order on the safe secure and trustworthy
development and use of artificial
intelligence this is by far the longest
executive order ever issued it is
absolutely worth reading um whether
you're a student or you're a senior Pi I
I do think you'll get a lot out of
reading this and here are some
highlights for us as we think about it
the first one is that there will be
certainly more interest and more um
activities in promoting the responsible
Innovation competition and collaboration
and investments in AI related education
training development research and
capabilities um so there's certainly
going to be a a renewed or upscaled
interest in research and training in AI
I found this to be a promising Avenue to
think about identifying and establishing
a program to attract top AI talent and
in other critical emerging Technologies
who might be at universities or research
institutions or private sector um
employment overseas and Expediting and
adjudicating the Visa petitions for
those talents to come and work here in
the US we will launch a pilot on the
national AI research resource I am so
happy to be a partner on the Nar as we
call it the Nar will launch its pilot
likely in January stay tuned but this is
led by uh NSF with doe DOD uh us and NIH
uh NASA Noah and other agencies we're
bringing some mighty resources to the
nare for you to use so I really look
forward to when that pilot launches
there are other activities such as uh
support for the Leading Edge accelerated
project this will be a Cooperative
agreement to improve health care data um
Quality to improve development of AI
tools for clinical care for real world
evidence programs and popul potion
health and public health related AI
activities this is all an HHS program so
stay tuned for that we're developing
those now and finally to support the um
nih's artificial intelligence machine
learning Consortium to Advance Health
Equity and research diversity and I will
talk about that one in a
moment so there's just so much promise
with AI as you know I love this story
it's the story of um how do you quickly
diagnose children who are born with a
rare genetic diseases um it's not enough
just to do the rapid genome sequencing
you also have to do the phenotyping and
the interpretation and that has
typically take took in a long time but
now researchers can use uh clinical for
example this in this example it's
clinical natural language processing um
to uh extract not just the sequencing
but to look at the uh clinical records
clinical notes and uh extract out what
might be a likely a phenotype of that
child and then compare it against a
database and when these researchers did
this they were able to get a a tentative
genetic diagnos in five minutes and it
usually takes a couple weeks so that is
that is just a wonderful promising
Avenue of research and work um but
there's also some challenges and one of
the biggest challenges in AI um or just
maybe in just data science is is using
proxy uh data for um making a
assessments or ass Asser assertions and
this is the aoxy here of a health
systems usually using AI um to make a an
assessment of the probability of a
patient coming into a health uh ER for
example or health hospital um and what
is their assessment of um risk and
burden what the proxy is is utilization
of Health Care so how many times a
person might go into a health care
setting or the cost that they might be
spending but in different populations
Access to Health Care is quite varied it
depends on things like ability to get
time time off of work ability to have
transportation to a healthc Care Center
as well as economic uh burdens and so
proxy data is often quite challenging
and is certainly um results in quite a
bit of bias when implemented in AI um
but there's certainly some opportunities
too so just to tell you a little bit
more about all of the many ways that it
is challenging um to utilize Ai and and
Health Data unrepresented of data such
as um us using data that's trained on uh
data that looks like people more from
the biobank UK biobank then the actual
population that you're interested in is
is going to result in quite a bit of
bias especially with training having the
um wrong question the data is designed
or the algorithm is designed with proxy
data but it's not really answering the
question you want it to answer or bias
in the algorithm in the implementation
lack not only of diversity not only in
the researchers but also in the people
who are who are uh participating in a
both from generate uh um giving data as
well as um those analyzing data and then
importantly um integration of social
determinants of Health into our data
models is super important and this is
Illustrated in this paper from jamama
Cardiology where researchers found that
by integrating um social determinants of
Health into their models to predict
heart failure uh they were had a much uh
better outcome for uh black patients so
so really promising notes
there I want to just briefly briefly
briefly overview some of the um progress
and examples that we've had with AI here
at NIH and it's not you see on the right
hand side the AI total budget and it's
not that we haven't been investing in AI
research before
2019 it is the case that we just started
measuring it and and um accounting for
it in 2019 these are data that are
reported to om so we know exactly um
what we're funding in AI um because we
started looking into that in 2019 and
you can see that the slope is is uh
going up quite a bit each year and I
anticipate this will continue supporting
really important programs such as bridge
to AI aim ahead the share data resource
share is a platform um to test AI bias
mitigation strategies it's supported by
the uh the National Institute of
minority health and health disparities
and by my office
odss to uh guide Healthcare Providers um
in Safe Systems for opioid prescribing
um as well as card supported by the
National Institute of Aging to extract
insights on disease risk and protection
factors from large networks of data and
finally improving operations in health
through developing AI computational
tools to improve screening we by the way
we use AI uh in our ni operations for a
number of things such as um looking at
conflict of interest per looking um at
ways in which we can send uh your grants
to the right study section and other um
other
capabilities there's a lot of ways in
which we're looking to make data that we
have already supported more AI ready so
I just want to quickly talk about you
know we have 250 plus pedabytes of data
a lot of that data is wonderful but it
may not necessarily be at the skill
ready for AI so things that we've been
supporting for the past couple years
include data cleaning importantly
imputation services for missing data
there's missing metadata this is a
really big field the study that we've
been happy to support ways to improve
data
representation uh ways to look at data
models one thing that I'm really excited
about is the way to think about
harmonizing data through developing
large language models that will
harmonize at the data model um and so
this is something that I've seen some uh
new gr applications coming in we've also
been looking at ways to remove spous
artifacts from heterogeneous data the
adoption of ontologies and standards to
improve
interoperability the ways to look at
data imbalances and biases and d and
data in the labels as well as ways to
think about um uh preparing and
integrating social determinants of
Health into um our applications for
artificial intelligence and finally and
the last the bottom bullet I do want to
call out um preparing data and getting
ready for algorithms that our multimodal
this is something that almost every um
talk I attend now on artificial
intelligence is about multimodal AI
something to be pay attention to and
think about as we really think about AI
at scale how can we think about
utilizing um AI uh data that is uh
connected across different data
streams just want to give a quick
example sorry have a little bit of a flu
Oh shoot sorry about that that's it's
me um some of the work that we've been
funding to do just those examples um in
creating and preparing data to become AI
ready for the past uh three years we've
supported almost $30 million um to
really get data to the point where it
will be AI ready and just uh noting
Nate's work um to develop methods for a
large scale genomic uh interval
comparison uh he's working to develop an
AI pipeline um
that will uh that will um take a genomic
and epigenomic data across different
data sources and look at ways in which
um we can uh take that raw data into a
consensus standard um standardizing The
annotation and making all this available
to the community um so that it can
become AI
ready one thing I do want to note is
that uh recently we put out a notice um
and you'll see it here about the use of
generative AI in peer review and because
uh the prompts in online services like
chat gbt or like Bard um do take your
prompt inputs and and save them uh that
potentially in fact does violate our our
um policies for confidentiality and
non-disclosure so uh there also many
other concerns about why you would not
want to utilize uh a generative AI model
for peerreview
of of Grants so please note that while
you are a peer reviewer um we do not
wish you to use generative AI um for the
analysis or formulating your peer review
CR critiques uh I know that might have
some discussion points but there's
there's certainly some reasons and we
could talk about why this this is not
something that ni would like to see
done I want to talk just very briefly
about the program um bridg to AI it's a
program that will generate Flagship data
sets um on challenging uh problems it
will prepare Ai and ml friendly data so
data that um really is ready at the
start of the the work to be um uh
trained for AI or utilizing AI
algorithms we also develop ethical best
practices for developing and utilizing
Ai and AI data and it will promote
diverse teams so let me show you a
little bit about some of the projects
that we're supporting and the first one
is precision for public health it's uh
using voice as a biomarker for
respiratory disorders for example or for
sleep apnea or for mental health uh or
neurological disorders and what it will
do is it will create a a database of
bioacoustic waveforms the ethical
components will look at voice hacking
capabilities and mitigation strategies
and the tools that will be developed
will be waveform compression and minimal
acoustic acoustic
quality
when we're thinking about multimodal AI
one of the programs that is certainly
out in front and center is the
functional genomics program it's going
to map the spatial and temporal
architecture of the human cell and it
will use those Maps um towards the grand
challenges of interpretable genomic to
phenotypic phenotypic learning so
they're going to look at approaches that
would look at a proteomic and masspec
data Spectrum spectromet data cell
cellular Imaging data and Gene genetic
data that's um looked at perturbations
through crisper and cast n so they're
going to create a library um and this
will be a pretty large scale library
because of the amount of data um uh used
um of cellular structure and cellular
function at the disease context level
using different cell lines so I think
that this is something that um will
certainly generate a lot of data and a
lot of capabilities for further
multimodal AI
investigations another program and this
is such a fascinating program is the
program on solto Genesis and this is a
program that um originally uh is born
out of the Holocaust where people want
to study how is it possible for for
folks who have undergone a very
challenging and difficult situation like
the Holocaust and come out relatively
healthy so here in this program they're
going to look at and create a temporal
atlas of pathogen pathogenes and
salutogenesis um by expanding
capabilities uh in clinical care and
they're going to look at this from the
lens of type 2 diabetes as a model for
understanding disease progression and
this is going to be in partnership with
um Native
Americans and finally the last um Grand
Challenge that's supported by bridge to
AI is the program on expanding uh our AI
capabilities in critical care they're
going to create a data set of over
100,000 patients from 14 ICU sites to
improve uh and develop uh AI algorithms
to improve recovery from acute illnesses
so this will also look at um developing
um phenotyping from Clinical notes via
large uh natural language processing so
these are all of the five grand
challenges supported by bridge to Ai and
each of these are its own Center and its
um own program what will we get from the
bridge to AI now will complete and
trustworthy data sets that are ethically
sourced and fair tools to accelerate the
creation of data sets for AI and
Community evaluation of data sets and
interdisciplinary training and research
and there's a a site there that you can
link on to learn more about riched
AI let me tell you a little bit about
the um Amad program and really the goal
of this program is to not only increase
the
participation of of folks who are in in
and Canen and in the development of AI
and AI algorithms but also in the
representation of folks who can both
benefit and contribute to AI so this is
it's about researchers and it's about
communities this program um does focus
on health disparities research usually
using Ai and ML and um to also improve
the capabilities of this technology in
these research uh institutions and in
the communities that um we utilize AI so
it's broken up into um a number of hubs
and you see the the each of the United
States with different color codes each
of those color codes are for example a
different Hub so today I'll talk about
the southeast Hub it's in purple and you
can see the states that it's covering
overall the structure of the Consortium
has a leadership core as well as
different cores to look at research and
AI training and infrastructure and all
of these activities happen in each of
the cores and each of the many different
institutions and communities that uh are
impacted by am ahead so in order to
explain this let me just tell you this
through the lens of the southeast Hub um
the pi NL Shankar from Mahari Medical
College and and his collaborators work
with over 93 different institutions and
141 Community organizations with 38
industry partners and over 1,438
HealthCare Partners and you can see all
of the different states that participate
just in this one Hub and so these hubs
are replicated across the US so what I
tell you here in this Hub um you can
imagine that there's similar types of
activities happening in the other
hubs so some of the work that we do uh
are pilot projects so funding new
investigators um who might be early
stage investigators uh with grants to
help them start their career and here's
the story of gum and GA um who's looking
at proteome wide Association studies
with Alzheimer's disease and
African-American uh populations and he's
basically doing a meta or a data reuse
analysis um utilizing the um the brain
tissue data from Wingo that's actually a
really good data set and he's looking at
prediction protein prediction models
what he does is he's now identified 10
new proteins I weren't previously uh
identified in the prior protein um pwa
study and he's looking to evaluate if
these proteins have any causal effect of
art of Alzheimer's disease in
African-Americans not only is he doing
research um in novel research in AI but
also there's trainees that are supported
by these Works including um Kayla who's
a undergraduate student who's learning
basic skills and programming she's able
to take what she's learned and do a
transcri transic white Association
analysis and was able to present a
poster at Lola and a master student
Daniel who's taken a course of machine
learning and then use what he learned to
do a transcripton prediction um in a
diverse po human population which
actually resulted in in his publication
this is exactly what AM ahead is doing
it's it's uh working with students
training them and in programming and
artificial intelligence and then helping
them do research so that they can
present posters and have Publications um
the goal is of course to increase the
number of people who can participate and
do research in Ai and as you will see in
the next slide also working with
communities so that communities can
benefit from AI as well and here's the
community uh project this is uh Greg
tardal uh who is working um in
Alexandria City public schools and what
he's doing and this is just such a cool
project he's developing an app um called
teens like me which uh teens can use um
in an explainable AI fashion so they can
learn a little bit more about themselves
and their questions um and think and
questions that they may have about their
health care so this is an app there's a
software developer and they work with
the students the students have an
opportunity to participate in the design
of the app they also have an opportunity
uh to test it and test its usability um
and they also get a lot of training so
they have training on what is uh
artificial intelligence what is
Computing Club experiments so they can
experiment with 3D um augmented reality
and then they get a lot of different
Tech talks so these are Tech students um
from the school system and they're all
Junior High School students and and
that's really a great age to engage uh
young people in
AI so I don't want to do the video that
will take too
also what are some of the
accomplishments of the Hub um we have a
number of Fellowship programs both to
leaders as Wells to new investigators we
fund pilot projects like the ones I've
explained to you um as well as uh
different types of institutional Awards
to support new people coming into the
program and planning grants for new
infrastructure and you can see some of
the Hub Publications and this work is
replicated throughout uh each of these
different
hubs
I just want to quickly highlight this um
this is another example this is from
Birmingham Alabama this is how Ahad
engages with communities here you see an
engagement strategy with the bridge the
gap program and am Ahad and what this
does is it it holds conversations with
communities about what are your health
concerns how how could Ai and ml help
you um what are some of the things that
we need to really think about when we're
developing algorithms to address your
health concerns can you um
engage with AI uh what would be some of
your ethical challenges and and so this
is really what is the start of the
process called codesign so when we start
to develop Ai and ml algorithms really
it's with the communities um in hand um
helping us along the way and this is
just such a wonderful um video here that
you can click later to see the ways in
which we're engaging communities to help
design and develop artificial
intelligence algorithms for uh health
questions that they themselves May be um
wanting answers
to just a quick note there's tons of
fellowships and pilot projects but one
of the things that I'm most excited
about is really the mentor mentee a
ahead connects program which was
launched at the beginning of the award
there are over a 1,500 mentees students
and folks who want to me be mentored in
Ai and then there's 8 over 800 mentors
senior level investigators or folks who
are Tech experts in AI who are mentoring
um the students over 500 members of Imad
connects and 61 different types of
groups and a lot of the activities we do
in um Amad is Outreach and this is just
an example of an Outreach we hold a
number of workshops um where um targets
might be for example an urban Indian
health organizations or tribal EP
centers the idea is to bring in
different communities to discuss
artificial intelligence and to
understand the problems that they may
have and a particular challenge of
course is uh the health disparities in
American Indian Alaskan
natives so looking towards the future in
artificial intelligence things that
we're really interested in is of course
to support New Opportunities and support
collaborations particularly in Social
Technical Solutions for artificial
intelligence U related to biomedical
research ethical AI um is certainly
something that we're very interested in
you'll see some of our goals to develop
social Technical Solutions for ethical
AI to create and validate approaches for
using synthetic and clinical data sets
to leverage new technologies such as
foundational mod models to accelerate
biomedical and behavioral research
developing new AI capabilities that
would translate up data to knowledge and
enhancing um our Partnerships through
different federal agencies and different
communities there's a number of funding
opportunities if you're interested in
funding in artificial intellig I'm
listing here five different
opportunities a couple of different
opportunities from cancer in terms of
digital health and artificial
intelligence looking at decoding the
neuros circuitry from the Mental Health
Institute this is actually part of the
brain initiative leveraging world world
data for Imaging again from cancer
looking at um understanding uh data
science and research in HIV and then
advancing computational approaches to
elucidate disease pathology um from uh
the addiction
Institute let me just quickly uh talk a
little bit about some of the training
opportunities um we need talent um so we
have partnered with uh the US digital
Corp uh to bring talented uh students
who have just either completed an
undergraduate or master's degree to come
to NIH and help us um uh really
translate Data Insights uh into um
actual research experiences so we have
done this pilot this past
year um and uh you have to apply through
the US uh digital Corp um the
applications will open either um in
December or in January there are five
tracks if you're a recently graduated uh
Bachelor student or Master student and
your your degree is in areas that cover
cyber security data science and
analytics data design project management
or software engineering consider
applying for this you come to NIH um for
two-year Fellowship um and you work
within an Institute or Center and you
work um on different types of programs
that put your expertise uh um to the
test here and really help us improve our
NIH environment in data science and it
infrastructure um we've had a number of
programs uh students who've come to a
different uh institutes for example
developing cyber security architecture
for nd's research Cloud I'm developing a
cyber and physical infrastructure for an
nlm and to create um prominent
technology products um based on sort of
an agile approach using a identifying
user personas and looking um and working
with the tech teams to help develop
those products both of those are at nlm
so those are just examples of what our
data path uh Scholars work on and if you
happen to be a more advanced uh
researcher uh and you'd like to do a
sabatical at NIH or you're from te the
tech field and you like to come to n for
one to two year sabatical consider
applying as a data scholar the
applications will again go out probably
um in early uh 2024 January February we
have a number of Scholars who've made
significant contributions um working on
everything to looking at um integrating
electronic Healthcare data with other
data and us program um to looking at PAB
scale search uh from genomics data
through nlm and
S you can come if you are interested in
a summer program you can come um to the
uh NIH as a summer student you have to
be a master student at the time of the
program you come for 10 weeks and you
work within our interal research program
as a data scientist there are some
training opportunities for example we're
supporting administrative supplements
for data science training um for
infectious and immune mediated diseases
this is supported by many institutes
even though the lead Institute is niid
um many institutes including my office
are interested in encouraging training
programs that would Foster trans uh
interdisciplinary collaborations between
biomedical behavioral clinical and
computational scientist so if you're
interested please do consider that
supplement where will data science go
over the next five years we hope to
improve um our capabilities uh and to
support the NIH policy for data
management and data sharing I didn't
talk about that today but that is a top
goal for NIH as well as develop programs
to enhance the use of human Drive data
such as electronic health care record
and other clinical data for research
providing opportunities for software and
computational methods in AI I didn't
talk about it but there are two new
funding announcements coming out
probably in January to support software
uh development and software
sustainability as well asoft research
software Engineers we're always
interested in in our data infrastructure
and supporting a Federated data
infrastructure and then finally as
you've seen supporting a broad community
of researchers and research in data
science and with that I think I have
exactly left enough time Jack for some
questions and again I'm sorry that my
internet kind of freaked out there for a
moment uh
but that always happens when you're
coming to talk never fails right there's
always some sort of technical thing but
H you you you rallied so thank you I
apologize for that if you want me to ret
tape no no no that's totally fine Susan
thank you so much for going through all
of that I mean there's so many different
things that I'm really glad to see the
NIH um taking these things on and I just
you know from my own experience over
quite a long time now of you know the
NIH there's always been this interest in
data science whatever it was kind of
called at that time it was computational
modeling or it was uh you know
informatics or bioinformatics or what
not and now it's you know it was a big
data to knowledge we were interested in
machine learning type things then now
it's this AI generative AI large
language model explosion and the NIH
always you know they I don't know
sometimes they would be a little
hesitant right um but now it really
looks like I mean you showed the the
graph there right that was it $300
million investments in in climbing um
I'm just kind of curious do you see that
Trend continuing it seems like there are
a number of programs which coming out
that uh that would hint that that's true
and uh I from what are you kind of
seeing from where you're
sitting oh I definitely suspect that the
interest in the funding support for
artificial intelligence um and
generative AI uh will be uh increasing
not just at ni but with within each of
our funding um federal agencies NSF do
doe uh other agencies as well DARPA for
example um this is this is partly
because of the executive order which is
really um you know not just saying uh
wonderful activities about artificial
intelligence in terms of a supporting
funding but actually asking for
implementation plans in a fairly quick
time frame
so I I do suspect that uh that that that
the the research into and the ability um
to get support for artificial
intelligence developments uh in
biomedical research will certainly
increase over the next um couple years
if not longer now that that's that's
that's good good news it's good news now
one of the things which you know I was
just driving into work this morning and
listening to NPR and there was a you
know some discussion I've remember
exactly what the segment was on but it
was talking about Ai and you know
basically replacing people's jobs and
you know a little bit of of concern
about you know the implications of AI
and so I always kind of get this sense
that AI as we've been talking about it
over the last year or so is sort of this
like Friend or Foe kind of Duality right
and I'm kind of curious you mentioned a
lot of positive things you did kind of
hint at things like bias or other things
which are maybe some of the downside of
AI um about you know you mentioned about
Diagnostics you know what happens if
diagn diagnoses are you know wrongly
generated by AI what what are some of
the the the the I don't know the
downsides that we need to be a little
aware of in biom medicine and what's the
ni's view on some of those do you have
any
thoughts yeah absolutely so um it's this
is a wonderful opportunity um to to
invest in the ability to create AI that
is a tool to help human especially in
our health care System here's an example
of where it can be really helpful um we
have a significant amount of doctor
burnout partly because of the pandemic
but also just the amount of um coding
and reporting of of interactions with
patients a lot of that um can be
summarized and extracted and developed
by something like a generative AI so
creating those reporting structures
helping doctors organize their notes
know being essentially a a tool that
really is helping organize and
synthesize information for a human to
then look at and to um to uh use it's
not making a decision it's it's simply
just a pro providing um a capability uh
for doctors to lessen their workload and
I think that's where it's wonderful
where it might be more challenging is um
when implemented um in a in ways in
which um there isn't that opportunity
for a professional human in the loop
interaction and that's where it does
become challenging and so you know there
because this is relatively new there's
certainly we don't understand all the
bias and the ways to mitigate those we
have to have a little bit of caution and
I think that's something that we're
really interested in investing in is how
do you have Assurance of AI algorithms
how do you know that you have taken care
of all the bias or all the potential um
drawbacks that might have been when
implemented so while it is it is
wonderful uh in a a great time for AI
you know I think the investment and and
insurances and and ethical AI is is
really needed so that we can get to that
point where um you know the the amount
of human in the loop can be a little bit
less I think you you raised a number of
exciting training programs um one's done
through aim ahead the US digital core
program I was unfamiliar with I think
that's exciting um and the NIH data um
Scholars Program it's great for anybody
who you know realizes they've got some
extra you know they got a sabatical
coming up and take advantage of that do
you have any programs or are you
familiar with any programs which are
really getting bringing the communities
together like the people who are
developing these Technologies bringing
them together with biomedical Educators
for example about teaching people how to
use these tools use them effective L
recognize when they're not working um
and that sort of thing are are there any
programs that are like that um through
aim ahead we do have programs that are
quite similar one of the things that we
do is we partner with um Health Care
Providers uh especially in clinics in
rural clinics or in clinics where um
there are underserved populations to
really uh work with them on the
deployment of of AI tools you could see
from the first V yes vignette that I
showed that um a AI Medical devices the
the implementation of those in in um
zobes with higher income is is is more
or less fairly robust but in lower
income uh settings or or unders settings
you can see that um the the interaction
with AI is is less robust so this is one
of the goals of AI and am ahead and we
are doing that I think that there could
be more uh and there there's a new
program compass that perhaps we we might
um through the common fund that perhaps
we might be able to leverage as well
well to really look at and work with uh
underserved communities and really at
the community
level suan in our final minute or so do
you have any parting thoughts you want
to leave us with about the importance of
AI in biomedicine and where you see
things
going I would say that um this is an
exciting time to be a student the every
day there's a it's almost impossible to
keep up with the literature and AI but I
can see the advancements in the research
in AI generative Ai and foundational
models is really moving forward the
largest uh investment that industry is
making in AI is in the health care
sector so if you're in this field and
you're you're you're Bridging the Gap
between biology medicine and computer
science and AI you're probably in a
really good place for for your next um
opportunity once you graduate or once
you obtain your uh PhD so this is this
is a really exciting time I kind of wish
I was younger because that this is just
such a fun time to be alive I can't wait
to see you know what happens in the next
five years and how much our lives are
improved um by the use of AI um because
it is a tool and like all tools it has a
good place uh for for humans and human
health Susan Gregor she's the associate
director for data science and the
director of the office of data science
strategy at the National Institutes of
Health Susan thank you so much for
sharing the Spectrum of things that are
going on at the NIH in this space it's
very exciting and I could not agree with
you more this is a super exciting time
to be a young person entering the field
um I like you I look forward to seeing
how all of this changes it'll be
completely different from when we were
kids right it will be so different oh my
goodness it will be so different um from
When We Were Young um it's just G to be
a wonderful time absolutely well Susan
thank you so much have a wonderful
weekend and a wonderful holiday we will
not be having a um a seminar series uh
next Friday but we will the following
Friday on December 15th so please join
us then in the meantime have a wonderful
weekend and uh a wonderful holiday Susan
thanks you again thanks Jack